hi everybody i'm jonathan Tron's and
today i thought for tactical challenges
we take a look at some games that were
played at the top level so with that
being said let's have a look
this position arose from the world blitz
championship in Berlin 2015 between
Magnus Carlsen and Sergey karyakin and
mitad Lee it was a blitz game but in
this position car Aachen missed a chance
to find a killer blow and finish the
game off in style go ahead and pause
your videos and see if you could find
the move
Sergey missed in the game
Sergey played King g7 after which the
position is still completely winning for
black and he did ultimately go on to win
the game but do you see what he missed
you'll notice in this position that the
rook is tied to the defense of the g2
square also the White Queen is tied down
to protection of the F pawn if you
haven't solved it yet go ahead and pause
the video again and see if you can find
it ok here comes the solution black here
can play the remarkable rook to a1 and
whites to heavy pieces are overloaded
neither piece can take the rook and
black threatens rook takes G 1 followed
by Queen G to mate so for example we can
look at if rook takes the rook this is
quite simple checkmate and in this
position if you take with the Queen this
is also a checkmate we simply take on F
to bring our bishop into the game and
deliver the mate thank you guys for
watching go ahead and let me know in the
comments below did you get this one
right go ahead and give it a big thumbs
up and I'll see you next week for
another tactical challenge